president shimon peres
[Music]
this week on q a our guest is daniel
shulman senior editor at mother jones
and author of sons of wichita how the
koch brothers became america's most
powerful and private dynasty
[Music]
daniel shulman author of sons of wichita
what's the book about
the books about the four koch brothers
the koch family
a lot of people associate the koch
brothers which is charles and david coke
um in fact there are there are four
brothers charles koch is named the
oldest uh frederick coke is and this is
really the tale of a historic um
industrial dynasty people associate the
most with their role in politics these
days
they have a fascinating business story
they have in my mind a really riveting
family story as well
which has you know included many years
of strife between
um these two sets of brothers
what got you interested in it
i thought that you know in the
2010-2011 time frame
um you see charles and david koch
becoming you know in my mind these
cartoon villains it was very much a
caricature of who these guys were
and once i started to peel back the
layers of that a little bit look into
their family background i said wow this
is a really you know politics in my
maybe that's the least interesting thing
about this family um in my mind i see
them kind of you know in the mold of the
rockefellers or carnegies in the sense
that
their legacy is going to extend in so
many ways
um you know beyond our lifetimes are
they all alive yes i want to show that
cover the book and ask you just a little
bit about each one of the four sure
as we look at the book cover down in the
lower left hand corner is fred
who is 80 years old born august 26 1933.
what do you what can you say about him
um frederick was the eldest eldest koch
brother he was not interested in the
family business he
has been a patron of the arts
and he's spent a lot of his life
rehabilitating a series of historic
homes around the world including this
really fabulous uh woolworth uh former
woolworth mansion on east 80th street
and he was actually kind enough to give
me a tour of of this home that he
actually doesn't even live in he's got
an apartment down at fifth avenue that
he actually lives in this is kind of his
private museum where he has all this
phenomenal artwork um he's also spent a
lot of his life uh collecting i guess
what you might call artistic ephemera so
like uh the cocktail napkin doodles of
jean cocteau um stravinsky's handwritten
scores the uh henry henry miller's first
manuscript drafts of of tropic of cancer
these sorts of things that are really
give you a lot of insight into the
artistic process and a lot of these he
now are
collected at yale's by nikki library
you wrote in your book about fred near
the end of the book frederick lowers
himself into an armchair in a second
floor sitting room
he has not spoken to the press in more
than 25 years since the british media
descended on him
like a pack and i need to
change the page here
uh
ah i get it here
like a pack of wolves even before that
he refused all interviews and stayed
conspicuously quiet as his younger
brothers savaged one another on the
pages of national newspapers and
magazines shall we delve into the coke
world he asks but first a formality he
unclasps a clear plastic envelope and
withdraws a crisp document quote if you
would sign this please it's a contract
requiring that quote all writing
pertaining to frederick r coke
including personal subject matter
revealed in research and interviews be
submitted for his approval is that you
he's talking to yes
how was your reaction when that happened
i think my heart stopped for a few
minutes and for a few moments and um
because this had come after a lengthy um
you know we'd had we'd spoken by phone
we'd um
uh he'd give me a lengthy tour a few
hour tour of his home
um
and of course this wasn't something that
i was going to be able to sign and
essentially what happened was we had a
little bit more back and forth
and could not come to
an arrangement that he was comfortable
with
so that's base more or less where our
communication stopped although he he did
you know respond to
my fact checking questions
when it came to that part of the process
how involved is he and the whole koch
world
you know he's kind of always been
somewhat on the outskirts of his family
he um
he went to boarding school all these all
the brothers went to boarding school but
he went to a boarding school
at an early age
he went to hackley in new york
obviously would come back on school
breaks and things like that but he never
got involved with the family company um
the other three brothers did
um and so he was a bit of an outlier and
in in his father's eyes he was a bit of
a disappointment
fred koch ended up partially
disinheriting frederick
according to charles this occurred
because frederick had had stolen from
him on a couple of occasions
including once forging charles's name on
the family's brooks brothers charge
account
now there's a early in the book you say
you quote somebody saying he's gay and
then right after that in a parenthetical
expression you say frederick says he's
not right why is that an issue
frederick frederick um emphatically says
that he's not gay um people that are
close to the family um say you know say
certainly say differently and and it's
been reported elsewhere um
that he is um but i just think and you
know frederick should have
the the last word on that if he says
he's not gay then that's
you know that's that's what he says
about the matter he didn't get any money
from his dad he did he in fact um two
trusts were created for him in the 1960s
but when and he ended up with about 14
percent of coke uh stock in what would
become koch industries um
the other brothers
shared about 20 percent stake they each
had a 20 stake in the company um but
frederick was cut out of their father's
will so in the end how much money did he
get
he ended up when he when he ended up
selling his shares in the company he got
330 million dollars let's go back to the
cover of the book which one on this
cover is charles charles is upper right
and he was born in 1935 he's 78 years
old he went to mit yeah
what more can you tell us about him you
know charles uh goes to mit uh gets two
advanced degrees including one in
nuclear engineering um he is a budding
libertarian at this point decides that
working uh in the nuclear sector means
he's going to be under the thumb of
government for his career and he box at
that notion um
he
kind of grew up in his father's shadow
um
always kind of the heir apparent and he
went to work for a consulting firm in
boston um and really enjoys being out on
his own making his own career making his
own way um
their father in the 60s is in sort of
poor health he's had heart problems um
and this is something that runs on on
their side of the family his mom had
also had died of congestive heart fred
koch's mom had died of congest
congestive heart failure um
so
fred is you know wants to hand over the
company to one of his sons and cause
fred koch is the father um
and
calls charles several times and asks him
to come home to
take a job at the company um charles
says no at first but finally basically
his dad makes him an offer he can't
refuse he says you know i'm going to
sell the company if you don't come back
and
and start working here um so he does
that and he really makes growing koch
industries at the time it was called
something else but after their father
dies in 1967
charles renames the company uh in his
honor and
he really you know makes his full focus
growing this company and you know today
he has grown grown it so much beyond
what his father would even recognize
it's you know it's it's kind of
remarkable private company
private company how much are
how much is he worth uh recently
bloomberg pegged his net worth at about
a little bit over 50 billion dollars but
i'll tell you a funny story which is as
i was getting this manuscript of the
book ready to go i had to revise the net
worth of david and charles coke upwards
twice
um originally i had it at 36 billion and
then together or each each worth 36
billion and then uh forbes uh the the
forbes list came out of the world's
billionaires they were at 41 billion and
then you know really as their as i
couldn't make any more changes in the
book uh bloomberg estimated their net
worth at 50 billion al jazeera did a
documentary back in 2012 and here's a
little bit of it showing we'll be able
to listen to a little bit of charles
making a presentation at one of their
donor meetings
attendees at coke meetings held twice a
year are sworn to secrecy but undercover
recordings were leaked to a blog
what i want to do
is recognize
not all of our great partners but those
partners
who have
given more than a million over the last
12 months
the kochs and their partners spent at
least 40 million dollars in the 2010 us
elections helping to shift the balance
of power in the house of representatives
towards right-wing tea party republicans
in colorado charles coke urged wealthy
conservatives to dig deep into their
pockets for the 2012 fight against
president barack obama this is the
mother of all wars we've got over the
next 18 months
for the life or death of this country
they are radical libertarians basically
they oppose big government they think
that the free market does better when
it's unregulated and the family's been
pretty much in in kind of complete
opposition to
everything that's been done in america
in terms of progressivism since the new
deal
that's jane mayer at new yorker magazine
she's played a role in this coke story
what is it sure um well hers was really
the first story that sort of uh
uncovered this under the radar family
for a family that was as influential as
they were
it was remarkable you know they were of
course known in certain circles but um
the extent of their you know corporate
empire and their political empire really
you know wasn't something that was well
covered uh before the 2010 time frame
and that's when jane mayer's story um
and you know the interesting impact that
had it it certainly riled up people on
the left um
but within the company it also
you know provoked a bit of a backlash um
certainly against against the media this
is this is what they viewed as the start
of you know a campaign of vilification
against the company
go back to what that documentary talks
about these secret meetings these donor
meetings the donor
group today have explain what that is
so the interesting thing about this
group is that it really started you know
charles and um richard fink who is the
pl his sort of political consigliere at
koch industries um you know started
these seminars in about the 2003 time
frame at the time these things were so
boring that you weren't clamoring to get
into them that's for sure they were you
know really economic seminars um
and eventually they would start um
you know bringing in members of a
variety of advocacy groups and other
sort of uh
libertarian-minded think tanks and
you know high net worth individuals that
were interested in donating to these
entities they would basically showcase
them and say well if you're interested
you know and such and such give to
this you know if you're uh if you're
against climate change maybe you should
give to our advocacy group here
americans for prosperity um now in the
obama era this became much more of an
organized endeavor
where you had them sort of much more
closely coordinating where the money was
going through
through coke's political advisors
and also you have these uh you have
these
lunch sessions where essentially there's
an emcee up there
you know a pledge-a-thon i guess you
could call it where all sorts of uh
conservative donors are you know
standing up and saying you know i'll
give a million dollars you know to you
know to preserve the freedom of this
country and that sort of thing um so
through this donor empi donor network
they were essentially funneling uh money
to an array of different organizations
some pretty closely linked to koch
industries
some in sort of an outer outer ring of
that orbit by the way and as we're
talking is there anything about this is
it that's illegal
no um i think they've been pretty
scrupulous about
um
making sure that their
activities are within the legal bounds
you know the one area where things did
get dicey and koch industries claims
that they had nothing to do with this
was uh in california there was an
episode that came under investigation
and groups were handed record fines for
this but um the koch's one of the coke's
outside political advisors a fellow
named sean noble
essentially accepted money from a
california political entity
and because of some sort of byzantine
campaign finance rules the money went
out of state sean noble was going to
route it back into the state and that's
where they ran afoul of campaign finance
laws now koch industries claims um they
had absolutely nothing to do with this
um
and uh it doesn't seem like the
california fair elections board was able
to definitely definitively prove that
link back to them if you had to show a
pie chart of
how they make their money where would
the biggest chunk be you know one of the
biggest things that they do is
commodities trading um they're the the
world's third largest commodities trader
um they make a huge amount of money uh
from that
they're also
big in oil gas petrochemicals um
anything that you could imagine that
derives from
derives from oil um
another big piece of their business is
is they recently in 2005 they bought
georgia pacific um the forest products
company so they have a huge number of
consumer brands um brawny paper towels
quilted northern toilet paper
and as well as built building products
all the sort of building products that
georgia pacific makes um we've seen fred
or they call him freddy i guess freddie
the oldest son who's 80 and he lives
where most the time
he has an apartment on new york's fifth
avenue where you know he is
for a certain part of the year but he
also has a collection of other houses um
he is one house in the south of france
near monaco
um he has he owns the former hunting
lodge of the archduke
ferdinand
outside of salzburg
and she also owns a historic estate in
butler pennsylvania not too far from
pittsburgh we're just talking about
charles what is his title and where does
he live he's the chairman and ceo of
koch industries and he lives in wichita
on on the same compound where he grew up
and he's 78 let's go back to your cover
and
now the twins which one on this cover is
bill
okay bill is bottom right corner
what can you tell us about him he's
74 years old 74 years old
bill got a phd in engineering from mit
he ends up joining the family company in
1974.
um
bill
you know bill had
always
been sort of a gawky
teenager
felt awkward um
and she had some childhood resentments
against his brothers bill um and
especially
his brothers david and especially
charles
this derived in part from the fact that
uh charles and david were always
quite close and bill sort of felt like
the third um and lesser wheel and he's a
twin
he's the fraternal twin of david's
um
and he felt growing up that uh charles
used to whip up a lot of uh
resentments and hostilities between the
between the twins and provoke fights
between them and indeed when they were
growing up they got into some real
battles um some some of them were so
fierce that they had a property foreman
that used to carry around boxing gloves
with him and would when these guys got
into it he would he would put their
boxing gloves on so they didn't really
injure each other where does bill live
and what does he do for a living bill
lives in palm beach and he uh he's
created a very successful energy company
called oxbow and this was after
um he was ousted from the family company
after essentially an attempt to take
over the board of koch industries does
he have any relationship today with his
brother david or with his brother
charles amazingly he and and david were
able to
bury the hatchet in this very after many
years of what has to be one of the most
brutal family feuds in history we'll get
to that in a minute here's some video of
bill talking about what his company does
i'm in a business where we make real
money
and that is and we we have some gas
drilling
we buy and resell petroleum coke which
is a carbon product from waste product
from oil refineries and sulfur
we process the petroleum coke we have
offices and a hundred different are we
do business a hundred different
countries and we have uh
40 or 40 different offices in 40
different our offices in 40 different
countries
our sales are about
all between three and four billion
and our compound annual growth rate
since 1984 has been 26 percent a year
what are his politics
you know the interesting thing about
bill is he's often can be associated
with lumped in with his brother's
politics
and he did give quite a bit of money to
mitt romney in the 2012 campaign
but he i wouldn't quite pigeonhole him
as a republican or as a libertarian
he once considered running for for
senate as a democrat in kansas um so
he's given to democrats and republicans
over the years
finally
david the twin brother david on the
cover where is he
okay david is upper left-hand corner
and tell us about david
um david you know the interesting thing
about david is that he was
really a gifted athlete um
he set records at mit on the mit
basketball squad that were really only
broken
in the last
in recent years
so he also goes to work outside of the
family company after graduating from
school he didn't he wanted to sort of
prove himself and learn um in in another
chemical engineering company um he goes
to work for koch industries uh in 1970
um for what was then called coke
engineering um
and you know david for many years had
had a sort of a reputation as a bit of a
playboy he didn't get married till you
know
well into his 50s um
but has a reputation as a pretty affable
guy um sociable sociable guy and you
know he's been
charles's partner in growing this
massive company over over the past
decades he was the candidate for vice
president on the libertarian ticket in
what year in 1980 and how active is he
now
on politics in politics
you know
in terms of that campaign uh i i i
certainly think that was you know he he
looks back on that experience fondly but
i don't think you'll see you'd ever see
him running for high office again um in
terms of his political activities he's
you know a prolific donor
to a range of conservative causes and is
also
on the board of directors of the
americans for prosperity foundation
americans for prosperity is the advocacy
group that the koch brothers founded
here he is in 2009 talking about the
american prosperity group and let's
watch
americans for prosperity
is nonpartisan
and that is essential at a time when the
very foundations of our nation are being
challenged
in all candor
we have seen both political parties come
up short and make disastrous mistakes
now more than ever we need a strong
principled freedom movement to hold both
political parties accountable and that's
exactly what american for prosperity is
doing
do you agree with the nonpartisan label
well they certainly target democrats
much more so than they do republicans
although you do have to say you know
that there's a situation right now in
detroit where
americans for prosperity has come out
against a plan to fund
the pension system there to the tune of
195 million and americans for prosperity
is essentially saying if you guys vote
for this talking to the republicans in
the state legislature if you guys vote
for this
we're going to target you for defeat so
in some instances they do go after
republicans
as well republican moderates as well i
should say how much money
have they given to politics in the last
20 25 years i think that's really hard
to quantify because um you know it's
certainly well into the millions but a
lot of their money uh doesn't flow to
the political system directly they you
know they've spent a lot of money to
influence the political culture through
a variety of think tanks and educational
institutions you know a lot of charles's
money charles koch's money has gone to
places like the mercado center he
founded the cato institute
david sits on the board of the cato
institute
it's through this way that they've
sought to influence the political system
it's not just through the funding of
campaigns and in fact um
in terms of you know they were said to
have spent 400 million dollars on the
last election you know i'd say a very
small percentage of that was probably
their money but what they were able to
do was bring together these resources uh
from a variety of contributors and and
harness a lot of that money and that's
why they're so they've been so powerful
politically your book has a lot of
personal information in it
about the four
boys for men
let's start with fred has he been
married
and does he have any children
no fred never married and he has no
children
what about charles
uh charles is married he's been married
for decades uh to to a fellow wichita
wichitan uh named liz and they have two
kids uh who are in their late 30s right
now are they involved in the company
uh charles's son uh chase is involved in
the company and he is um actually that
he was actually promoted not too long
ago to president of i believe it was
it's the company's fertilizer division
and he also i think is on the board of
directors in the company he's been
certainly being groomed for bigger and
better things there although the topic
of succession is always a touchy one and
charles never really fully answers that
question um you know basically his
response is often we have such a great
you know range of leaders within the
company you know if i'm no longer here
there's any number of people that could
take over um how many times has he been
married
only once and what about bill
um
bill uh bill has uh i think five
children
by four different uh women he's been
married three times
um
and his kids range in age from i think
you know late 20s to
you know he i think he has a toddler but
they're not involved with cocaine no not
at all and then finally what about his
twin brother david um david uh has only
been married once uh his wife's name is
julia um she
hails from arkansas i believe and was a
former um
assistant to the fashion designer adolfo
when he met her um they have three kids
and their eldest is in his teens david
lives in new york and you say that his
wife had trouble when they first got
married
getting along with some of the doyens of
new york city explain that yeah i mean
david
david traveled in some high circles um
and you know his wife was not you know
she's she's
by all accounts she's a very
down-to-earth person um she was not a
society lady and when you all of a
sudden go from you know having to chair
the met gala there's a bit of a learning
curve um and there is certainly some
cattiness at the upper echelons of new
york society and she was certainly on
the receiving end of that there were
some nasty
um
you know some nasty snipe anonymous
sniping in the gossip pages and things
like that and i think she was pretty
hurt by that
other than fred did any of the others
talk to you
um no no but i was able to talk to
you know a number of people who know
them pretty well um including very close
friends of the brothers um the you know
godfather of of david's uh eldest son
people of that nature did they have to
get the approval of the koch brothers
for
them to do that i think some of them
probably called the coax and said hey
i'm going to talk to this guy is that
okay
um
others
others just talked back in 1993 harry
reid said this on the floor of the
senate
who is this so-called
non-partisan grass root
group
that calls itself citizens for a sound
economy
i'd like to point out a few facts about
this group
this group
has as its top officials
a family
by the name of coke
these
officers these coke family members
are
known for their ultra and i stress ultra
right wing conservatism
and i think
even this statement gives conservatism a
bad name which it really doesn't deserve
they are extreme rightist i'm sorry i
mentioned the word conservative
that was 1993.
he's been beating this drum a lot longer
than i realize i suppose
that's the first one we could find yeah
and just to jump ahead here the
washington free beacon which is owned by
a foundation the center for american
freedom which is a counter to the center
for american progress a left and a right
uh has put together a video you might
have seen it that uh shows
uh mr rita on the floor of the senate
mentioning the koch brothers 134 times
we're just going to run a little bit of
this because it goes on for a very long
time and what this is
recent that they put this together in in
this year let's watch
koch brothers koch brothers koch
brothers koch brothers koch brothers
koch brothers billionaire koch brothers
charles and david coke charles and david
koch charles and david coke cokes cokes
cokes coke cokes cokes cokes cokes cokes
cokes coke cokes addicted to coke coke
dollars coke money coke back coat back
coat back coke surrogates coke products
coke ads coke funded coke funny koch
brothers coke brothers koch brothers
koch brothers hook brothers koch
brothers koch brothers coke brothers
coke brothers coke brothers coke
brothers cook brothers koch brothers
coke brothers koch brothers coke
brothers coke brothers coke brothers
koch brothers coke brothers koch
brothers koch brothers koch brothers
koch brothers quote brothers coax
immorality koch brothers radical
philosophy koch brothers lies these two
brothers are trying to buy america
what's going on
you know in terms of
why people see
harry reid and other senate democrats
seemingly running running against the
koch brothers in these midterm elections
is i think because
the
you know a
their advocacy group americans for
prosperity has been out there
hitting these vulnerable senate
democrats early and they've been hitting
them often and it's having an effect um
i think the the democrats
use the have seen the name coke at this
point as a good fundraising tool um they
know it it rallies the left
so i think that's part of the strategy
that you're seeing unfolding
on the senate floor right now when
uh senator reid is
denouncing the koch's um left and right
but i do and i've said this before i do
think it's a bit of a dicey strategy
when when you say things as senator reid
has when you call these brothers
unamerican
and things of that nature which i think
would rub most people the wrong way
here's ted cruz on the floor of the
senate having another view of this
so when the majority leader stood on the
floor of the senate and said this is all
because of the nefarious koch brothers
set aside the impropriety of the
majority leader of the united states
senate picking two private citizens
individuals who are engaged in political
speech standing up for what they believe
and the majority leader using his
position of political power to lambaste
them
to target them interestingly enough the
majority leader does not seem to have a
problem
with a california billionaire who's
publicly pledged to put a hundred
million dollars behind democrats
to press them to pass climate change
legislation that would cost millions of
jobs across this country from blue
collar workers from hard working
americans
that billionaire in the majority leaders
view is perfectly fine
to spend a hundred million dollars in
the election but but the koch brothers
because the two of them have stood up
and expressed their views
are subject to vilification and personal
attack
comment
you know what's interesting to me about
all this is that i i have somewhat of a
theory that the democrats have helped to
build the koch brothers into what they
are politically today
through by in some ways demonizing or
villainizing them what's interesting
about the kochs is they really aren't
republicans they're libertarians and
there's quite a difference between those
two philosophies now you really have
they've long had a really uneasy
relationship with the republican party
now you have the kochs
being embraced by
a lot of people on the right
largely because they've come under such
withering attack
by the left
you know you if you delve into all these
organizations
including the magazine you represent
there's these connections you drown in
all these connections and i want you to
help us out here uh to start with
why aren't people upset about george
soros you know
he's on the left and he's there's an
opensecrets.org has a big piece about
the
the kind of money that he spent which is
tremendous amount of millions of dollars
yeah no i mean i think you have a
situation right now um where
speech is you know money can equal
speech and i think that's a problem on
both sides of the aisle where the the
more money you have the more you know
democracy um you can buy um in terms of
folks like george soros he was
extraordinarily politically active in
the 2004 election you haven't seen him
as active in recent cycles um
the other difference that i see between
george soros and the kochs
and people bring this up often and it's
a very fair question
is the kochs i think have been a bit
more methodical
in their efforts to change the political
culture and to build
um a political
network and this has been a process
that's been going on for 50 years um
that where they've been working at this
in order to make sort of mainstream some
of their libertarian views
if you go back to what we saw earlier
the secret meeting that was held in
colorado uh
i read that philip anschutz was in the
group he's a multi-millionaire
billionaire he lives out in colorado but
he also owns the examiner newspapers and
he owns the weekly standard and the
washington free beacon has on its board
bill crystal who runs the weekly
standard and then when we go to your
magazine mother jones there's all kinds
of connections
did people come after you from the right
when you started writing this book
because you're associated with mother
jones you know not too much um uh
you know there was a story i'm trying to
remember it was in newsmax and it said
something you know
which is a very conservative
conservative magazine and it basically
you know new book to target the koch
dynasty um brought up my mother jones
affiliation and you know implied that
this was going to be
um some sort of an attack but you know
i think what you see is a lot of the
reviews saying you know this is actually
people are kind of shocked that this is
just an you know a pretty
straightforward even-handed look at the
kochs and i really wanted this to be
a book
that
both you know republicans or democrats
could read this book and both learn
something from it i mean you spend a lot
of time in this book not on how they
spend their money but on their
background when did you decide to do
that
you know i think it goes it went back to
some of my early research when i when i
was realizing that
like i said you know i wanted to
understand the origins of this family
and their ideology um
but they also have this really riveting
and and really dramatic sometimes tragic
um
family drama that took place and
um
i was just
interested i was just so interested by
it what would you do if you didn't have
the transcripts of coke v coke and tell
us what that is boy um so coke v coke is
this massive this lawsuit that played
out between the four koch brothers
charles and david on one side um bill
and frederick and other shareholders of
koch industries in the other and
basically what happens is in the late
1970s um
bill coke is working in the family
company with his brothers charles and
david um
this was at a time when uh koch
industries comes under scrutiny by a
number of government
regulators including the department of
energy
then the company gets hit with a set of
indictments
for
allegedly trying to fix a federal oil
lottery
bill and other
shareholders most of them family members
of these members of the extended family
are grow concerned with the direction
that the company's heading in
bill attributes some of the stuff that's
befalling the company to charles's
anti-government
philosophy
another issue is this is a very closely
held private company and charles is
really driven to build this company
he's plowing all of their profits back
into growing the company and you have
bill and other other shareholders that
have on other interests
bill's an extraordinarily wealthy man
but only on paper and he wants to buy a
home but he has to
take out a mortgage for it which she
just views that as kind of ridiculous um
this culminates in a boardroom showdown
that charles ends up thwarting um bill
bill frederick and a couple of the some
other company shareholders were
essentially trying to expand the size of
the board
and this would have ended up deposing
charles as the as the chairman uh and
they would have taken a greater role in
the direction of the company um the end
result is bill is tossed out of the
company a few years later by his brother
by his brothers um and there's a really
dramatic moment um in the book where you
know
the board has to sit down and decide
bill's fate and david who is you know
really feels like a powerful kinship
with his brother of course um
with twins grew up you know
sharing the same room and they could you
know they could pinch each other at
night they were that's how close they
slept um
you know so is torn apart between
loyalty to his twin and fealty to
his elder brother um who is running the
family company and in the end he can't
bring himself to vote against bill um
the motion carries without him
and but he's glad that he doesn't have
to vote against bill because in his mind
you know you're not just voting him out
of the company you're you're severing
him from
you know from your life
um so what ends up playing out is a few
years later in 1983
they are able to come to a settlement
where where charles and david buy out
the dissident shareholders for 1.1
billion um of which frederick gets 330
million um bill gets 470 million and the
rest go to some
other family members a couple years
later
bill uh
bill believes that they've in fact been
cheated on on how much they received for
for their shares they think that the
company obscured assets and
and
they actually ended up selling their
price at a far too low price this
ignites litigation that goes on for
another
um about 15 years and it wasn't just
this one lawsuit there were you know
there were a number of lawsuits that
followed that you know bill
was
uh
you know to say he was obsessed would
might be
understating it um he went out after his
brothers
with a vengeance where's fred in all
this
fred frederick had remained on the
sidelines of
at first um their mother was of course
devastated mary mary mary coke she was
just devastated by what it what was
taking place between her sons she felt
helpless
she
reached out to frederick on a number of
occasions and and just you know
she didn't want him getting involved and
but eventually you know his lawyers met
with bill's lawyers and
um
he was sufficiently convinced that
there you know he had been essentially
defrauded um and he he ended up joining
this
this suit again
rick frederick and bill against charles
and david yep when was the trial what
was the big trial the big trial was in
1998
um and the outcome of this trial is that
the jury found that there had been
misrepresentations that were made during
the negotiations but these these
misrepresentations were not
material meaning that frederick and bill
would not be entitled to the damages
that they were seeking in your book
you're writing bill this is about bill
but then almost in the same breath he
expounded on grievances that went back
to childhood his absentee parents poor
self-image the bully of an older brother
who instigated fights between the twins
and every time bill neared the top of
the storm cellar during games of
of king of the hill shoved him roughly
to the ground i mean that's just a minor
part of the things they said about each
other oh yeah i mean basically you know
what i was getting at there is that bill
was always trying to position this as
purely a business dispute but that was
really quite impossible because you know
these brothers were trading the most
acrimonious of charges um
at one point you know charles and david
accused their brother of being mentally
unstable and things like that
both sides hired private detectives to
dig into their each other's personal
lives i mean at one point bill uh
privatized uh working for bill allegedly
were bribing janitors for the trash of
charles and david and their lawyers and
things of that nature bill believed that
people working for koch industries had
actually infiltrated his offices um at
one point they actually created a dummy
document left it out in plain sight
overnight
and according to bill and his lawyers
this document eventually surfaces in a
legal filing by koch industries
basically basically proving their
assertion that
someone had been infiltrating their
offices how deeply
were the wounds in all this you say
brother bill and david got back together
it's hard to imagine
that
these wounds could go any deeper because
in addition to this case bill had was
also pursuing
a whistleblower case against his
brothers um alleging that alleging that
their comp legend that koch industries
had stolen oil from federal lands um
essentially branding his uh his brothers
as
criminals um so you know that that that
cuts pretty deep um
amazingly
bill and david are able to reforge their
relationship um according to family
friends
part of this had to do with their their
wives
who were both the same age
were quite helpful at
kind of helping them restore their bond
they both have kids that are the same
age
they own homes that are basically two
miles apart in
palm beach
own homes near each other in aspen
so basically they started getting
together and it was a very
slow process but you know they they are
now you know consider themselves quite
close you have some uh video on their
website that will just run a little bit
of this showing the twins
when they were how there they are
boxing yeah and i mean it gets to be
pretty vicious here
the these uh
where did you get this
interestingly
um
some of this family's most private
moments played out
uh in courtrooms and this this was part
of a videotape that
was entered into evidence in one of the
legal cases um this one actually had to
do with their mother's will when bill
and frederick contested their mother's
will charles and david submitted this as
evidence to show that their mother was
in fact in you know
fine mental shape because she actually
narrated parts of this video this is
really just a small clip of what was a
compilation of
family footage
but this shows you some of the the
boxing battles that took place i mean
this one was a very
you know good-natured one some
apparently weren't as much so but um
fred koch their dad was a college boxer
tough guy um taught his kids how to
fight and things of that nature how much
was their father fred involved in the
creation of the john birch society
you know he was actually present in the
room when robert welch the founder of
the john birch society laid out his
vision for this group
and after that he became one of its
national leaders um you know when you
drive into wichita uh in the 19 in the
1960s on the edge of town there was the
the impeach earl warren uh billboard
classic john birch society billboard and
uh wichita was
essentially one of the hot spots of
bircher organizing at that time largely
thanks to fred koch how much did charles
get involved in john burke's society
charles koch joined the john birch
society um he says you know because
largely because of his dad um but he
seemed quite in taken by the john birch
society he actually um created one of
the
the goals of the birth society was to
create um
a series of christian science-like
reading rooms around the country um they
called them american opinion bookstores
charles
and a family friend actually started an
american opinion bookstore in wichita um
i also heard a kind of entertaining
story about just how deep their
anti-communism ran in the coke household
which is that um a family friend once
you know comes to the door of their
house carrying a copy of ernest
hemingway's the sun also rises charles
answers the door sees the book's cover
and you know there's some hesitance
there the visitor asks uh is everything
okay charles responds you know politely
you gotta leave the book outside and
this is because hemingway they
considered hemingway to be a communist
and even that type of literature was not
allowed inside the house
one of the people at and back in the
back of all your source notes you tell
us who you talked to and interviewed one
of the people you interviewed was a guy
named michael oliver yep who was he
michael oliver was an artist in wichita
kansas an art professor in wichita
kansas meets mary coke
in you know in the 1980s and really
becomes her very close companion um in
her final years of life is really
spending you know uh day and night with
her during these times and they travel
together
and that sort of thing um that so so
that's basically that's that's who he is
and why did he talk to you
michael
just
loved mary to death
and he
yeah i think he felt as if her story
could become
overshadowed in the broader tale of
these
you know powerful
important guys
um
and he really wanted to
talk about
you know
things like you know because mary coke
was a really fascinating woman in that
she was
elegant
but also she was a crack shot you know
she wore fur but it would also not be
strange at all to see her in fishing
waiters you know fly fishing in you know
stream in the flint hills of kansas um
or something like that um when did her
husband fred die he died in 1967 and
when did she die she died in 1990
december 1990. oh she was in i think she
was 83.
and you say that michael at that time
oliver was 45. yeah he was i think he
was a couple years younger he might have
been a couple years younger than david
at that point what happened about that
romance in in wichita
there were certainly a lot of whispers
um that he was a gold digger and that a
gigolo um these sorts of things but um
these were just two people that you know
by all accounts just enjoyed each
other's company and i think i think the
brothers were
wary um although she was she had a lot
of younger companions in the years prior
to that um who would sort of help escort
you know escort her around and things
like that so perhaps they'd been they
got a bit used to it um but i think they
were of course wary at first um
you know who is this guy why is he
taking such an interest in our mother um
but eventually um according to michael
they they warmed to him and you know he
and david would play tennis and things
of that nature in the end how much
control did she have over where the
money went that she had it when she died
you know she um
her estate was obvi was very much
smaller she she
didn't it was you know we're talking a
few million dollars really um
uh as opposed to what what fred coke had
and what what his sons had so we're not
talking about a huge amount of money
she put a no i shouldn't i should
qualify that say not a huge amount of
money to guys that already had a massive
amount of money um
now she inserted a clause in her will
basically saying uh if any of my sons
are involved in litigation against each
other at the time of my death
they will be disinherited um she hoped
this would carry enough of a sting to
end the lawsuit that frederick and bill
had been waging against their brothers
but it you know really it only ignited
another round of litigation
when you read the transcript from co
coke v coke uh
where did you find it and how long did
it take you to read it
you know i was i got uh transcripts and
court records from a variety of lawsuits
interestingly the koch v coke a lot of
the documents associated with that
lawsuit are actually stored in a literal
salt mine um in kansas somewhere um
uh we were able to i i had a great
assistant who was able to help me track
them down and then we had to figure out
the large the logistics of um
getting them transported to a place
where they would allow me to look at
them they ended up allowing me to look
at them in a courthouse in wichita
kansas um but so that was just one you
know i was all over the country tracking
down
documents um
including you know uh i i found a lot of
letters that fred koch had written um
during
during his birch society days at any num
at a variety of of archives around the
com country including the hoover
institutions archives um
you know i even got documents from you
know a russian
archive uh showing some of the work that
fred koch had done in the soviet union
um in the 1930s so i was i was looking
for anything i could get my hands on
you know there's a quote that i wrote
down uh it's from a man um by the name
of uh oh goodness where is it if i can
find it here
well it's jerome um oh okay liveships
yeah uh
so that was fred koch's minder when he
traveled to the soviet union
in the 1930s and this this was a
formative experience for fred koch
because
he
um
a his work in the soviet union really
formed the seeds of the family fortune
um basically he'd been sued in the u.s
and and forced to look for oil
engineering work outside the u.s he ends
up
getting a five million dollar contract
with his uh partner to modernize
modernized refineries throughout the
soviet union um and
when he travels there to oversee the
work jerome lifshitz who is an old
bolshevik is his sort of minder who
takes him around um the country um and
according to fred he tells them you know
the plans that the communists have to
subvert um the united states things
things like you know we're gonna make
you rotten to the core
and when he sees fred off at the train
station he basically shakes his fist at
him and says you know i'll see you in
the u.s sooner than you think or
something like that and so this is an
image that haunts fred fred um here he
is he's helped to modernize the soviet
oil industry which had really been
decimated at that point um helps to
industrialize the soviet union empower
the soviet union and
you know he returns home vowing to do
everything he can to
you know fight back against this
communist menace and um you really see
that in his work the john birch society
and this this really forms um some of
the ideology of of the family and of his
sons you were born where
i was born in new york city
where did you go to college i went to
college in boston i went to emerson in
boston did you study i study writing
literature and publishing
you got a master's degree at columbia
journal i got a master's degree at
columbia journalism where do you live
now
um i spend a couple days a week here in
washington dc um but i mostly live in
cambridge massachusetts these days
that's where my wife was getting a
master's in where she currently works
and what do you do full-time
i'm a senior editor at mother jones
okay i'm going to wade through a little
bit more of this research that i did on
on mother jones and
you know all this the there's a coke
website that's cokefacts.com that the
family has out or the the industries
people have there's a website that david
brooks runs it's on from the left it's
the american bridge 21st century
foundation then on mother jones who was
i guess a socialist she was basically a
turn-of-the-century
labor leader who um led campaigns you
know against child labor in minds and
things of that nature but i want to ask
you those how you as a journalist stay
independent it's funded it's owned by
americans for prosperity the foundation
i believe no um found it's the the
foundation that runs it is called the
foundation for national progress my my
mistake but i did see that there's
contributions from bill moyers through
the schuman foundation
barbra streisand that's her her uh
foundation americans for prostitut i
think let's just leave america for
prosperity and david and lucille packard
fund uh there's there's a lot of
politics in all of this how do you stay
independent
you know what's so interesting is that
when you're bringing up some of these
names i'm saying to myself wow
streisand funds mother jones um uh you
know honestly some of this like
i'm not even aware of um
you know i don't know
there's certainly never been anyone
telling us what we should or shouldn't
cover and mother jones historically has
a has a reputation as a fiercely
independent um
you know muckraking um
magazine david corn runs the washington
bureau yep and he was all involved in
the mitt romney tape the 47 yeah david
david broke the um 47 percent video um
which is certainly one of the you know
one of the biggest groups scoops of what
has been a very uh illustrious
journalistic career um he was actually
the also the person who sort of broke
the whole valerie plame
saga during the during the bush era as
well so on your book
anybody disappointed
i think uh you know i've received some
in the social media world i've gotten
some
critiques from the left from people who
said we're upset that i
you know essentially humanized them too
much that but that's what my goal was to
do was to you know these guys had become
these two-dimensional characters and i
wanted to paint a full portrait of who
these guys are
there are certain people that believe
that the cokes are evil no matter what
and they're of course entitled to their
opinion um but
i i certainly didn't come away with that
notion um at all um so but no i mean i
think the the response to the book has
been overwhelmingly
good better than i could have expected
did you ever get the sense that you were
being investigated while you were doing
your research by the koch family no um
no i got the sense i i got the sense
that they were tracking the things that
i was doing quite carefully
um
what you know one thing that i do recall
is that
i interviewed one of their friends out
in wichita and i recorded the interview
and i asked
i asked uh if i could record it this
gentleman said sure but would you give
me a copy of the interview uh once i
returned home i sent him a disc
with the interview on it and i followed
up a couple days later just to make sure
he received it
got his secretary on the line and she
said to me oh so and so from coke just
came by to pick it up
and there was a pause
and she just had realized that she
shouldn't have said that to me um but
that's but that was the sort of that was
the sort of thing they clearly wanted to
know what i was up to at one point um
their communications director and their
general counsel flew out to new york to
meet with the editor
the editor who's working on my book they
really wanted to be sure that this was
going to be a fair minded account
daniel shulman author of sons of wichita
how the koch brothers became america's
most powerful and private dynasty we
thank you very much for joining us it's
been my pleasure
[Music]
for free transcripts or to give us your
comments about this program visit us at
qna.org
q a programs are also available as
c-span podcasts
[Music]
you